لانه ابن دوله كم عاش بيطلع شي اربعين
دولار بياخذوا من هون للماس وبيتير ما هو
اسمه معاش
سامحو الشغل
فبلاش تشتغل على السياره والنمره
عندي ولدين
يتعلموا بالخاصه حتى من الاولاد عم يخترب
بيتنا اكتر كل ما بقدر امنها
مثلا الولاده يروحوا يلعبوا
ابسط سبل العيش في بلد يعيش اكثر من نصف
سكانه تحت خط الفقر
وفيما استقرت نسبه الاثرياء على خمسه في
المئه تراجعت نسبه الطبقه الوسطى من 70
الى 40% صار من السبعه واربعين سنه عم
نشتغل مثل واحد عمره 20 سنه قبل الظهر
وبعد الظهر يعني عم نشتغل ميه شغله لنقدر
نكمل حياتنا
تقف الحكومه عاجزه امام دعم الاسر الاكثر
فقرا حيث تمكن خمسه في المئه فقط من
الاستفاده من برامج الدعم الحكومي غنوه
يتيم العربيه بيروت